We will now go through another
example to consolidate our
intuition about the content
of the law of iterated
expectations and the law
of the total variance.
The example is as follows.
We have a class, and that class
consists of 30 students
in total who are divided
into sections--
the first and the
second section.
Let xi be the score of students
i, let's say the
final grade in the class.
We consider the following
probabilistic experiment.
We pick a student at random,
uniformly, so that each
student is equally likely
to be picked.
And we define two random
variables--
X is a numerical random variable
that gives us the
score of the selected student.
So if student i is selected,
the value of the random
variable capital X is xi.
And capital Y is defined as the
random variable, which is
the section of the selected
student, so that y takes
values 1 or 2.
We're given some information.
For the first section,
the average of the
student scores is 90.
For the second section,
the average of the
student scores is 60.
Given that information, what is
the expected value of the
student score?
Well, each student is equally
likely to be picked, so has
probability 1 over
30 to be picked.
And this multiplies the score of
the student, so this is the
expected value of the random
variable of interest.
What is this number?
Well, we need to calculate
the sum of the xi's.
The sum of the first 10 xi's is
equal to 90 times 10, and
the sum of the xi's in
the other section is
equal to 60 times 20.
And we carry out the
calculation, and we find that
the answer is 70.
Now let us look at conditional
expectations.
If Y is equal to 1, this means
that a student from section
one was picked.
And within that section, each
student is equally likely to
be picked, so the outcome of
this random variable is
equally likely to be any
one of these xi's.
Each xi gets picked with
probability of 1 over 10.
And so, the expected value of
this random variable is 90.
Similarly for the second
section, the expected value of
the score of a randomly selected
student, given that
the student belongs in that
section, is equal to 60.
With this information available,
now we can describe
the abstract conditional
expectation,
which is a random variable.
This random variable takes the
value of 90 if a student from
the first section was picked,
and the value of 60 if a
student from the second
section was picked.
What is the probability of this
event that the student
from the first section
was picked?
Given that the first section
has 10 out of a total of 30
students, this probability is
1/3, and therefore, this
probability is 2/3.
Now that we have the
distribution of this random
variable, we can calculate the
expected value of this random
variable, which is 1/3 times
90 plus 2/3 times 60.
And this number evaluates to 70,
which of course, it's no
coincidence, it's the
same as the average
over the entire class.
By the law of iterated
expectations, we know that
this quantity should be the
same as this quantity.
So the law of iterated
expectations allows us to
calculate the overall average in
the entire class by taking
the section averages, and weigh
them according to the
sizes of the different
sections.
It's a divide and conquer
method, and it is similar to
what we have been doing when we
use the total expectation
theorem to divide and conquer.
We continue with our example,
and here is a summary of what
we found so far.
The conditional expectation is
a random variable that takes
these two values with certain
probabilities.
And the mean of this random
variable is equal to 70.
Let us now calculate
the variance
of this random variable.
This random variable, with
probability 1/3, takes a value
90, which is this much away from
the mean of this random
variable, which we square.
And with probability 2/3, it
takes a value of 60, which is
this much away from the mean
of the random variable.
We square this, as well.
And when we carry out the
calculation, we find that this
number is equal to 200.
Let us now continue.
And suppose that somebody gave
us this piece of information.
For the first section, this is
the deviation of the i-th
student from the mean
of that section.
So this is the sum of the
squares of the deviations and
then we average over
all the students.
We will use this data to
calculate certain quantities--
for example, the variance
of the scores
in the first section.
Now in the first section, with
probability 1/10, we pick the
ith student that
has this score.
And this is the deviation of
that student from the mean of
that section.
So this is the same as the mean
squared deviation from
the mean of the section.
And this is exactly the variance
within that section.
It is the variance of the random
variable, which is the
score of a random student, given
that we are selecting a
student from the
first section.
For the second section,
the story similar.
We're given this information,
and this tells us the variance
of the student scores within
the second section.
So now we can describe the
abstract conditional variance.
It is a random variable that
takes this value with
probability equal to the
probability of selecting
someone from this section,
which is 1/3.
Or it takes a value of 20, which
is the variance in the
second section.
And the second section is
selected with probability 2/3.
With this information at hand,
now we can calculate the
expected value of this random
variable, which is 1/3 times
10 plus 2/3 times 20,
which is 50/3.
At this point, we have the two
quantities that are necessary
to apply the law of
total variance.
According to the law of total
variance, the variance of the
student scores throughout the
entire class is equal to this
number, which is 50/3, plus
this number, which is 200.
And this is the overall
variance.
Now let us interpret
the law of total
variance in this context.
The interpretation
is as follows.
The variance of the student
scores in the entire class
consists of two pieces.
The first piece looks at the
variance inside each section,
which is 10 or 20, depending
on which section
we're looking at.
And we take the average over
the different sections.
So we look at the variability of
the scores within a typical
section, and then we average
over all the sections.
The other term looks at the
means in the different
sections, and figures out how
different are these means.
How much do they vary from the
overall class average?
It measures the variability
between different sections.
So the overall randomness in the
test scores can be broken
down into two pieces
of randomness.
One source of randomness is that
the different sections
have different means.
The other source of randomness
is that inside each section,
the students are different
from the
means of their section.
And these two pieces of
randomness together add up to
the total randomness of the
student scores as measured by
the variance of the
entire class.